welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Sonic the Hedgehog I can now
say with confidence will not scare the
hell out of your children which as a
kids movie based in 90s nostalgia that's
really all we need to enjoy it that
fanservice continues into the movies
post-credit scenes which I'm gonna break
down for you guys but spoiler warning if
you haven't seen Sonic yet I'm not
trying to ruin lives here just
explaining the big questions every nerd
is asking including the math I did on
how many people Sonic would kill with a
SuperSpeed
watch if you dare okay the Sonic movie
has two in credit scenes one right after
the closing title a second in the mid
credits Nimba don't worry there's no
stinger at the very very end of the
credits but hey you know maybe stick
around anyway to press that for all the
VFX artists who rushed to redesigned
Sonic and you know spare your nephews
innocence okay the first of these scenes
catches us up with Robotnik in the
movies final act sonic opened a portal
to the mushroom planet that he plan to
escape to if earth ever became too
unstable for him but sonic blue NOx
Robotnik into this mushroom world and
now in this indian scene he has gone
full Eggman he has shaved his head he's
fluffed out his moustache looking just
how we know him from the Sonic games and
after being stranded on this planet for
a few months he promises to return home
by Christmas and he possesses one of
Sonic's quills and then carry insanely
but very humorously robot marches away
the second post-credit scene is the big
reveal and another spoiler warning just
be safe we find ourselves in the hills
the leaves rustle in cyclone and then a
ring portal opens and out hops tails
tails read the scanner and says to no
one in particular because he's alone if
these readings are accurate he's here I
found him I just hope I'm not too late
and then it's too bushy Fox tails
separate and he jumps off the cliff and
then he floats with his tail
helicoptering him off into the distance
to move we all know and love from the
days of say now what's crazy is
including tails like this and Eggman on
the mushroom planets when combined with
some Easter eggs we saw earlier in the
movie this all seems to be setting up a
Sega verse now look having to go through
all these movies in trailers
shot-by-shot
looking for clues explaining everything
constantly deadlines chasing that nerdy
news cycle all while keeping a smile on
my face it just ruins everything out of
me sometimes the walls of this blue
dungeon
like sonic is just running circles how
many consonant rapidly in this blue hell
if only I had an escape one that you
would understand and not judge me for
well folks I think I found one
thanks to raid shadow legends for
sponsoring this video yes we all raised
adolescents down here raid is a free
turn-based RPG with a ton of champions
to choose from
I like opening shards to summon new
characters like this level one lurker if
I don't like the champion I summon I
head on over to the tavern to sacrifice
them and to upgrade to another champion
it's the circle of life
rage shadow legend style you can play in
campaign mode and enjoy a fully voiced
story or head over to the arena to fight
other players one-on-one raid is
cross-device so you can play with the
same user and switch between mobile and
your desktop that's helpful when I
played so much rage shadow legends that
my phone battery dies and I can't call
my mommy to pick me up from Arby's the
graphics are amazing the PC version in
the game is super fast as well you can
find me in the game under the username
new Rockstar and if you are quick enough
you can also join my clan so what are
you waiting for go down to the video
description click on the special links
and if you are a new player you will get
100,000 silver in one for each champion
slasher you may be an ugly lizard guy
but he is a real sick champion and hey
these awards will only be available for
30 days to jump on this all of this
treasure will be waiting for you here
good luck and I'll see you there ok back
to what these sonic post-credits scenes
could mean for a future possible Sega
verse a term that should only feel weird
coming out of our mouths because yeah I
guess everything diverse now if we look
back to the first act to the movie sonic
began on a planet that was clearly based
on the Green Hill Zone from the game the
mushroom planet that he had as a
fallback refuge is based on the mushroom
Hill Zone so clearly it looks like
they're building a universe out of the
levels that we remember from the game
the reason sonic has to escape this
green hill planet to earth is because
he's under attack by a tribe of echidnas
the animal that knuckles is now knuckles
doesn't make a cameo in this movie but
the echidnas we see do have spiky
knuckles just as he does
Sonic's mentor figure is a new character
an owl named Wong claw she teaches them
how to use rings to open portals clearly
tails also has the
we don't know tails came from the same
origin planet that sonic did it probably
did but if tails is joining this
universe you know knuckles and the
others are probably on the way if this
movie gets a sequel
there was an easter egg earlier in the
film showing a map of planets laying out
various alternate origin and destination
points at Sonic's the universe of
characters could arrive from Sonic at
one point does say everyone travels
using ring teleportation where he's from
suggesting this could be how tails and
possibly one davy echidnas and knuckles
will join the fray perhaps knuckles will
run into Eggman on the mushroom planet
and knuckles will recognize Sonic's
quill that he has meanwhile Eggman would
obviously be super interested in the
echidnas Chaos Emeralds those could be
when the guns for the sequel now in the
scene tail says I just hope I'm not too
late
suggesting that Sonic remains in danger
maybe some new threat sonic isn't aware
of the tails is and perhaps he is
referencing the echidnas but what do you
think this new threat is comment down
below with your sequel theory no way you
should join the inner circle discussion
about this stuff that we are having on
new rockstars official discord you can
get access to it by becoming a patron
today at patreon.com slash new rockstars
follow me on instagram and twitter at VA
vas follow the new rock stars and
subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube or break downs of everything you
love thanks for watching bye
[Music]